the new year will mark the official
start of recreational marijuana sales in
California and there are fears it could
lead to more impaired driving among US
drivers killed in crashes who tested
positive for drugs more than a third in
2015 had used marijuana Barry Peterson
visited the University of California San
Diego where researchers are trying to
help police detect whether a person is
too high to get behind the wheel part of
the study we wanted to get at memory
issues when you drive on Tom Marcotte
simulator at the University of
California San Diego he's not checking
how good a driver you are but how bad a
driver you may become high on pot move
to the far right lane and take the
freeway exit so the idea of the off-ramp
is actually something that the police
suggested to you because in their
estimation that's one of the areas that
are most difficult for impaired drivers
to handle the real tough subjects light
up some with a real joint others with a
placebo then they are put through the
simulator challenges like deciding
whether it's safe to drive through a
yellow light they also face a
multitasking test finding the right
circle it's all designed to eventually
create a tool perhaps a tablet test that
police can use roadside to determine if
someone is too stoned to drive the
ultimate outcome is to see whether or
not we can really help law enforcement
separate those people are impaired due
to cannabis or those people may have
cannabis in their system and are not
impaired unlike alcohol there is no
accepted marijuana breathalyzer blood
tests can be inconclusive depending on
when the test is taken and to make it
more complicated pot effects different
people differently well there are
indications that the more experienced
you are the more tolerance you develop
so a person who smokes a lot might
actually have less effect when it comes
to driving that's correct because their
body is adjusted to it they know what to
expect
California Highway patrolman sergeant
Glen Glazer jr. teaches officers how to
recognize a driver under the influence
how much does this
making it a kind of a judgment call if
that's the right word well I think it
very much is a judgment call because we
want our officers only arresting people
who are impaired right now officers
mostly rely on subjective observations
like walking the line or is there a pot
smell in the car and while a lot of
Californians are looking forward to
January 1st when recreational pot goes
on sale Glaser and police across the
state are braced the big scare is going
to be those people who are going to try
it for the first time come January 1 and
not knowing how it effects their body
one day the simulator may lead to an
answer and help catch someone impaired
by pot before getting too high gets
someone hurt for CBS this morning Barry
Petersen San Diego I'm glad they're
figuring it out some guidelines not easy
yeah yeah I just don't think you should
get behind the wheel of a car
ya know any second thing I agree when
you're intoxicated no no no you stay
home and write if you got to do it